if John Kasich has struggled quite  literally to make it to center stage in  this race so far don't rule out him  still having a major role to play if for  the one very simple reason that John  Kasich is the governor of a state you  have to win to take the white house in  Ohio he reminds us he's presided over a  success story that is a model for  America as a whole problem is that he's  been drowned out by his rivals and at  times has seemed like an irascible voice  from the sidelines a nine term  congressman a fox news host an  investment banker he's been around a  long time it seems to spend an awful lot  of it now trying to persuade people he  is conservative in him we've got people  proposing health care reform it's gonna  leave I believe millions of people  without adequate health insurance let us  happen to our party what has happen to  the conservative movement if you really  can deliver Ohio maybe there is more  likelihood of John Kasich for vice  president of the ticket